María Clara Buenas tardes Taiwán es para
Guatemala la única y verdadera china Así
lo expresó la cancillería de este país
centroamericano en días previos a la
visita que recibe hoy de la presidenta
taiwanesa quien justamente fue recibida
por el canciller Mario bucaro en el
Aeropuerto Internacional la Aurora de
ciudad de Guatemala desde donde fue
trasladada al Palacio Nacional para
reunirse en este momento con el
presidente Alejandro yamatei ambos
mandatarios están firmando acuerdos de
cooperación y de inversión de acuerdo
con la agenda y más tarde realizarán una
declaratoria ante los medios de
comunicación la visita de Saint in Wayne
a Centroamérica se da apenas días
después de que Honduras país
centroamericano hubiera roto relaciones
con Taiwán si hubiera Aliado con china
una movida que recientemente también han
hecho otros países de Centroamérica como
Nicaragua El Salvador y Panamá de manera
que Guatemala queda como el país más
grande de los 13 del mundo que todavía
Taiwán como un estado soberano y según
el gobierno de Alejandro yamatein esa
relación diplomática de 62 años
atraviesa por su mejor momento pero aquí
Cabe destacar que esa cooperación de
parte de Taiwán hacia Guatemala ha
alcanzado en periodos del 2013 al 2021
los 90 millones de dólares 3 millones
más que lo que le ha dado la Unión
Europea a Guatemala pero eso le ha
costado que haya habido momentos
críticos como en el 2014 cuando el
expresidente Alfonso Portillo fue
acusado de haber recibido Dos punto
cinco millones de dólares de un soborno
taiwanés para mantener esa relación ese
estatus de nación a la isla asiática